grâce à cette performance
je pense qu'on va peut-être faire un
petit pas d'allant
dans la jeune trentaine seesus aline
comédienne blogueuse journaliste est
bien connu à stockholm elle affirme
avoir été victime d'un viol il y à 11
ans déjà rapporté à la police cinq ans
après l' affaire a été classée sans
suite a eu un impact sur ma vie pendant
des années j'avais peur je devais être
certaine que je pouvais aller à tel ou
tel événement
la suède c'est très petit l'automne
dernier dans la foulée du scandale wild
thing
elle est une des premières suédoise a
dénoncé publiquement son agresseur sur
son compte instagram
le journaliste vedette perdra son emploi
quelques semaines plus tard en suède qui
passe pour le paradis de l'égalité des
sexes et de la liberté sexuelle seesus
aline s'inscrit dans des statistiques
bien troublante
nous n'avons pas de liberté sexuelle en
suède
il y à une centaine de viols par jours
ce n'est pas la liberté c'est plutôt une
prison sexuelle la suède est bel et bien
le pays où le taux de crimes sexuels est
un des plus élevés au monde
l'an dernier 20 viols par jour y ont été
rapportés en bonne et due forme à la
police pour une population d'à peine 10
millions en hausse de plus de 200% en 15
ans pourtant l'égalité des sexes y est
sur toutes les lèvres depuis des
décennies et les hommes consacrent
énormément de temps à la famille dans
cette garderie où les parents
accompagnent leurs enfants
on compte bien plus de papas que de
moments ici en suède
on est très sensible à l'injustice dans
la foulée d'autres têtes ont commencé à
tomber comme cet animateur très
populaire d'une émission de bricolage
diffusé par la plus grande télévision
privée du pays
plusieurs femmes l'ont accusé de
harcèlement mais le grand patron de la
chaîne n'entendait pas en rester là
dabo this is turning point ce n'était
qu'un début
il fallait voir si c'était une exception
ou un comportement plus répandue à
partenaires
problème conclusion il n'ya pas de
batteur les grâce à une investigation
indépendante télé 4 s'est débarrassé de
quelques autres présentateurs
plus encore elle s'est dotée d'une
charte intitulée tolérance zéro qui doit
être respecté par tous il nous fallait à
tout prix regarder plus loin
trouver une solution à long terme à
partir de cette expérience douloureuse
pour avancer tout l'été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tv4 comme plusieurs autres institutions
suédoise avait-elle vraiment le choix
depuis trois mois un véritable tsunami a
déferlé sur la suède
des dizaines de milliers de femmes ont
décidé que c'en était assez
je pense que c'est ce mouvement a pris
tellement d'ampleur c'est aussi parce
que l'airé des têtes connues au début
qui on est et qui est qu'ils sont tombés
journalistes et correspondants à
l'étranger elisabeth frère au travail à
tv4 depuis près de 25 ans avec des
centaines d'autres elle a signé la liste
mitu des journalistes hashtag deadline
liste sur laquelle on trouvait aussi des
centaines de témoignages anonymes
relatant les agressions sexuelles est le
harcèlement dans le monde des médias
la force de ce mouvement m'a surpris oui
parce que ça fait quand même des années
qu'on parle de ce problème et nous on
fait des reportages tout le temps là
dessus mais qu'il y a un métier chaque
jour qui sur liste pendant des semaines
et des milliers de milliers de femmes
qui signe un sas était patent du tour en
suède le mouvement me doit dépasser tout
ce qu'on a vu ailleurs dans le monde
une déferlante de limite ou dans à peu
près tous les milieux
chez steam désignés officiers de police
depuis 25 ans est mère de trois filles a
lancé la liste hashtag autodéfense ce
stand up down stay en trois jours nous
avions déjà 2000 membres cotation en
bourse aujourd'hui elles sont cinq mille
c'est plus d'une policière suédoise sur
trois le harcèlement fait partie de leur
vie depuis qu'elles ont été admises dans
les forces de l'ordre il y as exactement
soixante ans on n'en parle pas une
culture du silence que chez stein a déjà
dénoncé dans un roman nous avons fait un
collier composé de cinq mille perles de
plastique représentant chaque membre de
notre mouvement
puis nous avons rencontré le chef de la
police on a déposé le collier sur la
table et on lui a dit cette perle
représentent celles qui ne dort plus la
nuit
celle ci une autre qui a quitté son
emploi et celle là cette femme qui
pleure chaque fois qu'elle vient
travailler et ainsi de suite
le cinéma et le théâtre n'ont pas été en
reste contrairement aux états unis ici
très peu de têtes ont roulé mais des
milliers de témoignages anonymes ont mis
au jour des agressions harcèlement quasi
systématique
voici les instigatrices du hashtag size
actions et hashtag backstage
nous voulions vraiment être anonymes et
les hommes dont on parlait devait l'être
aussi
c'est très important de ne pas envoyer
de message qu'un tel est un monstre et
les autres sont sans problème
nous voulions exposé la structure et la
changera vraiment la phase 2 dans la
lutte pour l'égalité entre les excès
c'est d'abord il est à la structure
officielle mais après il faut changer
les attitudes et elle est là avait un
vraie prise de conscience dans nos
familles tout et équitable les hommes
s'occupent beaucoup d enfants de leurs
soins quotidiens de tout mais au travail
nous ne sommes pas arrivés encore les
suédoises ne sont pas seuls dans cette
bataille plusieurs hommes ont sauté dans
le train en marche
le ministère des marchés financiers a
pris l'initiative de convoquer toutes
les compagnies d'assurance et les
banques du pays le ministre les invite à
réfléchir aux solutions nomades rock
session n avons la responsabilité d'agir
via nous tous c'est pourquoi j'ai
convoqué cette réunion
je voulais entendre l'opinion des gens
si nous avons l'impression que le milieu
ne prend pas les choses suffisamment au
sérieux
le gouvernement devra agir juste avant
noël la campagne hashtag mis tout est
dans le parlement suédois a voté une loi
sur le viol qui fera l'histoire
dorénavant l'accusé devra démontrer que
l'acte sexuel était consenti
ce ne sera plus à la victime de prouver
l'agression dans toutes les sphères de
la société suédoise
les attentes sont maintenant énorme sexe
sexe dans les cas d'agression sexuelle
ce n'est pas une question c'est
mais plutôt de pouvoir nous voulons
changer la structure du pouvoir pour
pouvoir changer la société
c'est comme une maladie l'agression
sexuelle ce n'est qu'un symptôme la
vraie maladie
c'est la structure du pouvoir c'est
vraiment le façon de voir le monde qui
est en train de basculer un petit peu
feng est ce qu hongbin chef
je pense qu'il y aura un changement je
n'abandonnerai pas la place des femmes
sur le marché du travail est en
politique
l'équité salariale le partage des tâches
domestiques dans tous ces domaines
la suède est aujourd'hui championne en
s'attaquant aux rapports de pouvoir
entre les sexes bien plus qu un individu
la révolution mythe ou en suède a
l'ambition de faire faire un autre pas
de géant aux femmes et à la société
suédoise
[Musique]